[Music]
gave a shout out to the cool ladies who
helped her during a really hard
quarantine
and the celebs have a connection they've
all publicly
supported brit during her ongoing
conservatorship battle
there's miley we love britney
britney like anyone else should have the
freedom to live the life that's most
authentic to her
and sharon stone um the girl didn't kiss
me
after the release of the framing britney
spears doc the longtime fan commented on
brittany's gram
you have a right to an attorney not
provided by your family
sarah jessica parker shared the hashtag
free britney and in 2019 natalie portman
talked about their childhood bond
we were under studies for the same show
when we were kids
then we met up again and we had a party
together rounding out britney squad
her younger sister jamie lynn she's
trying to make the best
and stay positive during a very
challenging time
and there's conservatorship news et has
obtained court documents from the latest
hearing
will you be taking over now for jamie
brittany wants jodie montgomery to
become permanent conservator of her
day-to-day affairs
which among other duties includes the
power to limit visitors and retain
security guards on a 24 7 basis
this comes as fans are on red alert over
some of britney's recent posts
last night's spear shared this pic of a
red fridge and two other recent posts
with the word red in the captions
conspiracy theorists are scrambling
wondering if there's a secret message
brit's trying to send
i'm sending all of you guys a lot of
[Music]
love